So first of all, we need our activity
to implement the various callbacks and
listeners that we've
been discussing about.
So, you can see here our public
class MainActivity already extends
ActionBarActivity.
We want to implement a few things.
So we want it to
implement the following.
It's going to implement
GoogleApiClient.ConnectionCallbacks,
GoogleApiClient.ConnectionFailedListe-
ner, and the location listener.
Instead of you watching me typing,
I'm just going to paste these in.
I've now added these, but
we can see we have a few errors
because some of the symbols
haven't been resolved.
You just need to import the correct
libraries to resolve them, and
I've added those libraries here.
We can now see that we still have an
error, and that's because there are some
methods that need to be implemented and
we haven't implemented them yet.
But we will be doing
that in just a moment.
Before we do that, there's a few
things that I want to add to the code.
First up, we just want to add a tag,
which is a string,
to the code that allows you to track
the name of this application if
we're writing it out to the log.
So we do that with a private
final string, it's called tag.
And you can put whatever
you like in there.
I'm just going to put LawrenceTestApp
and the code would look like this.
Next there's a few local variables that
we need to set up within this class.
Things, for example, for tracking
the text view that we call TxtOutput,
the Google API client itself,
and a location request object.
So I'll add these now.
You can see when I added them in,
it detected that it needed
to import this class.
So just go ahead and say okay to that.
And the class will be imported.
So you can see here I have a TextView
object that I'm calling txtOutput
that will just be used to
address the TextView on the UI.
I have a GoogleApiClient that
I call mGoogleApiClient.
And I have a LocationRequest
that I call mLocationRequest.
Okay, now in our onCreate method,
we need to set up the GoogleApiClient.
And we use this with
a GoogleApiClient builder, and
we add the requisite APIs to that.
Let's add this code and
then we can talk through it.
So, we go to onCreate and
I'll add the code in here.
So what it simply does is it
creates a new builder for
an API client, and it adds that we
want to use the location services API
by saying just LocationServices.API
to the addAPI method.
We want the connection callbacks on the
Google API client to come to this class.
And we want
the OnConnectionFailedListener
also to come to this class,
and then we build it.
So that's now going to give us a Google
API client that allows us to talk to
Google services.
Now, if you remember,
we had a UI element called a text view.
And this will render
the location information.
Of course, we want that text
view to be addressable in code,
using this txtOutput class.
So let's set up something
to do that right now.
And we do that like this.
We just specify that txtOutput is found
my looking for the ID, or .id.txtOutput.
If you remember, when we specified the
text view in the XML for the activity,
we called it txtOutput,
the same name as this.
We just find that view and
then we cast it into a text view, and
now we're good to go.
So just to recap,
what did we actually do here?
Well first, we created an instance of
a Google API client using its builder.
We set it to use
the LocationServices API here, and
then we told it what the callbacks for
OnConnectionFailed were this,
so we're going to be handling
them within this class, or
within this activity, and
then we hooked up to text view to code.
You've actually done a lot but
there's still more to come.
So let's have a quick quiz first.